as the left enters day five of mourning
dead Iranian terrorists Qasem Soleimani
the outcry takes an explicitly
traitorous turn we examine an important
political reality you are known by the
friends you keep then the most prolific
rapists in British legal history is
sentenced to life in prison
but even amid the me2 movement virtually
no media outlets are reporting on it we
analyze a story that doesn't fit the
leftist narrative finally some big
little endorsements in the 2020
Democratic primary and a proposed split
in the Methodist Church over same-sex
marriage all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
big news in the Democratic primary we
will get to who won the coveted Judge
Judy endorsement but before we can get
to that we have got to cover what all of
the other Democrats in America are up to
and that is mourning the death of the
world's most notorious terrorist Kazaam
sulamani I don't want to be accused of
hyperbole here so I've plucked just just
a handful of random examples of major
leftists in this country actually
mourning this guy actually taking the
side of Iran over the United States
actually posting glowing tributes and
elegies and reviews to this dead
terrorist sulemani here's just a little
quick montage somebody on Twitter put
together of the mainstream media
shedding those leftist tears he was a
war hero the commander of Iran's feared
could fourth Qasem Soleimani was no
ordinary general the u.s. officially
classified him as a terrorist but in
Iran he was a national hero he's
regarded as personally incredibly brave
the troops loved him I was trying to
think of somebody I was thinking of de
called a revered figure in Iran and some
other places in the Middle East smart
charismatic ruthless strategic and bold
his power made Iranians proud but even
many of sulemani enemies admitted he was
a military genius Qasem Soleimani was an
evil genius
sulemani was in charge of spreading
iranian influence around the world and
he was extremely good at him he is the
think of the French Foreign Legion you
know if you will by killing Qasem
Soleimani the US has stripped Iran of an
inspirational military leader the crowds
are massive and emotional there are many
tears here thousands of mullahs on the
streets in Iran symbolic caskets are
lost weeping and chanting I am the
Lamoni leader of Iran weeping and
praying over a coffin draped in the
Iraqi flag is difficult to convey how
revered he is it's difficult to convey
how revered he is among the mainstream
media Qasem Soleimani the u.s.
officially called him a terror
but terrorists really liked him as
though that's sort of some contradiction
they compared him to Charles de Gaulle
and compared them to the French Foreign
Legion I mean I don't know where they
get all of these comparisons from bold
ruthless courageous so handsome you just
melt in his eyes oh okay simcha SEM I
mean really really pathetic stuff add on
to that the the Washington Post headline
highly revered military leader you know
the Washington Post which called al
Baghdadi an austere religious scholar
from in the future by the way I would
like to be referred to only by my
mainstream media title of highly revered
austere religious podcaster so please in
the mailbag wherever you address me
please
I want the mainstream media treatment I
want to be treated as good as the
mainstream media treats terrorists that
is just the press and nikki Haley former
UN Ambassador and governor of South
Carolina went on Fox News on another
cable news outlet and called them out
for it you don't see anyone standing up
for Iran you're not hearing any of the
Gulf members you're not hearing China
you're not hearing Russia the only ones
that are mourning the loss of Soleimani
or our Democrat leadership and our
Democratic presidential candidates no
one else in the world because they knew
that this man had evil veins they knew
what he was capable of and they saw the
destruction and and the lives lost base
from his hands totally she got it
exactly right the only thing Nicki left
out is the mainstream media but she
referred to the Democratic leadership
and that includes the mainstream media
that pretty much is the mainstream media
so I guess she included that too but it
isn't just them it isn't even just the
elected Democrats it isn't just the
mainstream media we will get two major
left-wing figures in this country who
are now explicitly taking the side of
Iran and joking about and threatening to
kill the President of the United States
we'll get to that in a second but first
how do I maintain my image as such a
highly revered austere religious
podcaster part of the way that I do that
is through my full head of hair okay
I've never been a huge hulking adonis of
a guy I've never been the bed
athlete in the world but I've always had
this nice head of hair and it's very
important to keep that head of hair two
out of three guys will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 so what's the good news
the good news is with today's
advancements in science keeps offers
proven treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and help you keep
the hair you have at half the cost of
your local pharmacy you don't need to go
broke to avoid going bald you don't need
to find some magical solution they got
it we know how to keep your hair keeps
offers generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there and some of you may have tried
them before you've almost certainly
never tried them for this price plus
keeps now offers a prescription shampoo
to help keep your scalp healthy two
prevention is the key keeps treatments
are up to 90% effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss things to
keep you don't have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription you can visit a doctor
online get your hair loss medication
delivered to your home it's got more
5-star reviews than anybody else right
now you can get keeps and you can keep
your hair the keeps treatment start at
just $10 per month plus for a limited
time you get your first month for free
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps calm /
anoles KO wles to receive your first
month of treatment for free ke e PS calm
/ knowles canada wles nikki Haley gets
it totally right the only people in the
whole wide world who were mourning the
death of sulemani are terrorists the
supporters of terrorists and the
Democratic leadership in the mainstream
media and even elected Democrats and
even cultural figures who are Democrats
Michael Moore one of the most prominent
left-wing voices in the United States
privately messaged the Supreme Leader of
Iran Ayatollah Khomeini and begged him
begged him not to attack us and
apologized for American apologized for
Trump and said he would deal with Trump
the left has been so whipped up into a
hysterical frenzy over this that they
are now slow
writing into the DMS of mullahs to
apologize for the president and beg that
Iran some little nothing country a
country that should not be recognized as
a nation-state after the Revolution that
country is threatening the greatest
country in the history of the world
please PLEASE mullahs don't bomb us to
death this is what Michael Morse tweeted
out publicly but I have just sent the
Ayatollah of Iran a personal appeal
asking him not to respond to our
assassination of his top general with
violence of any kind but rather let me
and millions of Americans fix this
peacefully now in in Michael Moore's
defense at least when he's begging the
Ayatollah of Iran to forgive us our
trespasses he's saying that the way that
we'll deal with it is through the
election right let allow millions of
Americans to deal with this peacefully
that isn't what many other prominent
leftists have been doing but this is a a
moral violation at the very least this
may be a legal violation because you've
got a private American citizen trying to
negotiate with the head of the foreign
state the Logan Act often comes up you
know these these sort of arcane laws
come up that every few years when some
private citizen deals with a a head of
state I don't think Michael Moore is
going to be a prosecutor for this but
it's a serious violation that that he's
doing I mean to basically betray your
own country and try to negotiate with a
major state funder of terrorism against
the United States against the president
United States really bad stuff and
Michael Moore isn't even the worst one
for from it
AOC AOC the future of the Democratic
Party according to the head of the DNC
Tom Perez AOC has been promoting Pro
Iran Russian propaganda on Twitter
regarding sulemani it's so funny I mean
the left always projects they always
accuse you of doing what they themselves
are doing so they've been accusing Trump
of promoting Russian propaganda
for three years the left prominent
leftists are actually the ones promoting
Russian propaganda with regard to Iran
so so AOC just liked on Twitter which
exposes this tweet to her millions of
followers a tweet by Rania Khalek who is
a journalist for in the now this is a
Russian propaganda outlet who tweeted
out quote a friend flying into the u.s.
says he hasn't seen so much security
since 9/11 the US is terrified of how
Iran will retaliate Iran won't attack
civilians
that's what al-qaeda does but it shows
this assassination did the opposite of
making Americans safer and our leaders
know it so this is just a flat-out lie
Iran regularly murders civilians its own
civilians and the civilians of other
countries and actually Qasem Soleimani
was personally responsible for much of
it a complete lie imagine if during
World War two you had Democratic
congressmen posting Nazi propaganda on
Twitter or fascist propaganda on Twitter
Japanese propaganda on Twitter good
thing there was a Twitter back in 1945
but really there wasn't the Democratic
Party as we know it today I mean the
this radical leftist Democratic Party
that would take the side of Iran over
the President of the United States that
is a new thing we haven't seen that
really before it's been growing over the
past several decades
that's aoc and that is a betrayal of her
country not just a OCA o'seas preferred
presidential candidate Bernie Sanders
goes on television goes on CNN the
Clinton news network communist news
network and compares the United States
action here in killing the world's top
terrorists - Vladimir Putin
assassinating journalists here's Bernie
this guy is you know was as bad as he
was an official of the Iranian a
government and you unleashed then if
China does that you know if Russia does
that you know Russia has been implicated
under Putin with assassinating
dissonance so once you're in the
business of assassination you unleash
some very very terrible forces why
kind of perverted logic is that but by
this logic if any country kills anybody
they're just as bad as every other
country well if a country goes in and
kills men women and children and then a
country kills the people who kill men
women and children that is not the same
action I'll put it more clearly if a
country is committing terrorism if a
country is targeting civilians if a
country is violating international law
and then a country goes in and stops
them from doing that those are not the
same act actually they're opposite acts
and Qasem Soleimani
was a major terrorist leader and what it
makes sulemani so dangerous well used to
before we just all over the black that
Airport
what makes Suleiman what you did make
sulemani so dangerous is that he wasn't
just a terrorist he also had the backing
of sort of a nation-state and that's
what Iran has done since the Revolution
is they play both sides of the
international system they fund terrorism
all around the world they violate all
the international norms and they try to
pretend that they're a regular
nation-state with all the privileges
thereof and they're trying to have it
both ways and we in this case stop them
from doing them when you have a guy who
is targeting civilians who is funding
terrorism around the world who's
violating international norms and then
you go in and take him out that does not
make you the same as that person it
makes you the solution to the problem
that that person was but this is what
the left always wants to do the left
wants to make America seem wicked seem
evil seem just as bad as the terrorists
and when we pointed this out about the
left over the past I don't know 10 15
years the left has shrieked and yelled
and said that isn't true well now we're
seeing it explicitly okay
not just Bernie Sanders not just AOC not
just these elected officials George
Lopez saw an Instagram post that said
that the Ayatollah of Iran was offering
80 million dollars for Donald Trump's
head on a platter and you know what
George Lopez said he said he'd do it for
half
George Lopez with his verified Instagram
account went on that post and said we'll
do it for half look I get it George
Lopez is a comedian that joke if you
made that joke as an offhanded blue
irreverent dirty rotten dark joke in a
bar with your friends I get how that's
sort of funny if you are making that
joke publicly particularly as the US is
potentially headed for a war that is a
bridge too far I mean it's funny to a
certain audience that hates the
President of the United States so much
that they're willing to side with Iran
that they're willing to make common
cause with terrorists over the president
but it's not funny to the rest of us
it's a bridge too far I mean it is
actual betrayal of your country and then
the best of them all this is my favorite
cultural figure taking the side of Iran
over Trump is a rapper named ti who is
siding with the Ayatollah Khomeini in
calls for death to America I didn't know
who t I was so I googled him we'll get
to that in a second here is what ti
tweeted out yup dot um-hmm
exactly what he said and by he he's
referring to Ayatollah Khomeini who is
calling for death to America ain't no
Iranian never called me no n-word
infested our communities wit dope and
then locked us up for it allowed the
police to pull us over and gun us down
with no accountability or enslaved us
and tried to act like Shi t ain't happen
so as I pray for our soldiers I'm also
gonna be praying for theirs this ain't
our war champ hashtag don't start Shi T
won't be Shi T hashtag Magga hats oughta
go first he misspelled auda he
misspelled a lot of things Magga hats
ought to go first what does that mean
ought to go first does I mean ought to
go be sent into war or ought to go be
wiped out in war first he then
tweets out afterward or instagrams out
afterward
riddle me this how come America can go
to other countries and wipe out evil
people but can't get rid of the KKK
right here Wow
relate profound stuff ti first of all
the United States did get rid of the KKK
he decimated that organization decades
ago that Democratic organization I'll
point out we did but now the reason that
we can't ban them from speaking the
reason that the ACLU came to their
defense is because we have freedom of
speech the same freedom of speech that
allows TI to spout his traitorous
idiotic propaganda look if i were king t
i wouldn't be saying this kind of stuff
but I am NOT King this is what Antonin
Scalia said about the First Amendment he
said if I were king I would throw in
jail every scruffy beard and sandal
wearing creep who burns the American
flag but I am NOT the King so that's the
reason we have free speech in this
country but he is actively taking the
side of Iran over the United States he's
saying yup exactly what he said about
the shove the shot if only it were the
show about the ayatollah khomeini
i didn't know who t i was so i looked
him up on wikipedia this is from
wikipedia just for those of you who
don't know who TI is either clifford
Joseph Harris jr. known professionally
as TI and tip is an American rapper
actor songwriter producer entrepreneur
record executive and author he must be
busy in 2001 Harris formed the southern
hip hop group P dollar-sign C alongside
his longtime friends and fellow Atlanta
rapper z' big country king mac boney and
c rod harris is also known as one of the
artists who popularized the hip hop
sub-genre trap music along with Jeezy
and Gucci Mane I hope that clears it up
I'm sure it's much clearer for you now
then I read further down his wikipedia
and it turns out that Ti is a complete
criminal degenerate TI was arrested
several times by the age 14 for dealing
drugs he was sent to prison on various
drug assault and weapons charges
in 2007 he was arrested for possession
of three unregistered machine guns and
two silencers and possession of firearms
by a convicted felon rested a lots more
over
years then arrested last year for
disorderly conduct and simple assault
and this is the guy
now siding with the Ayatollah of Iran
what's it very interesting about the
first thing that he posted in his
agreement with Khomeini is he blames
everybody else for things that he did
right so he's blaming other people I
don't know who them white people
Americans I don't he's blaming others as
he's got this sort of racially loaded
post for infesting our communities wit
dope
nobody infested your communities with
dope whatever your communities are you
dealt drugs for your entire life
basically and you got arrested for it
and you take no accountability for it
you take no responsibility everybody
else it's their problem somebody else
made you have all those illegal machine
guns it wasn't you you're a poor
oppressed victim T I somebody I don't
know I don't you were just holding those
machine guns for a friend
and those silencers and you were just
dealing those drugs for a friend I'd
it's a huge misunderstanding a huge
mistake aren't you a victim you and you
and the Ayatollah of Iran you're both
just such a victims of America give me a
break
he says he says that the the people who
are doing this have no accountability
you have no accountability you take no
accountability at all this guy ti is
such a degenerate he posted a video last
year the of a music video that he was
going to release in which he very
graphically has sex with Melania Trump
in the first office this was so edgy
that they actually wouldn't let him
release it it never came out
that is ti that is the kind of person
who is siding with the Ayatollah of Iran
over Trump all of which brings us to a
very important political reality you are
known by the friends you keep you are
known by the friends you keep if you
find everybody everybody listening if
you find that your ideological allies
are all vicious
stupid selfish prideful unaccountable
terrible people maybe you should
reconsider your political philosophy
maybe there's something wrong with what
you're thinking if you find that you are
siding with terrorists and mullahs and
criminals and traitors over the
President of the United States
regardless of who that president is
Obama Trump Democrat Republican
left-right if you find that you were
siding with the worst people on earth
over the President of the United States
maybe you should rethink your political
philosophy maybe something has gone
wrong in your stream of logic you know
it's a logical fallacy to appeal merely
to Authority so to say my argument is
correct because this very smart person
believed it or my argument is correct
simply because this wise revered austere
religious person believed it over
history you can't merely argue from
authority but Authority does carry
weight Authority always carries weight
and the question is what authority are
we appealing to when you just look at
the clusters of people who are siding
with sulamani here who are attacking
Trump for killing the world's most
notorious terrorist who is it it's the
the mullahs of Iran the the worst people
on earth I mean they're probably the
most dangerous of vicious of vile
political figures on the planet
certainly in the top three the most
traitorous American politicians who
vacation in the Soviet Union ooh
honeymoon in the Soviet Union who don't
know anything who are terribly ignorant
of American history who spread Russian
and Iranian propaganda who who post
disgusting videos of them having sex
with the first lady in the Oval Office
who joke about killing the President of
the United States I mean if if you're
siding with these people wake up look
around you thank you
maybe I got this wrong and take a step
back you see
Louis has this line about progress he
says the whole idea of progress
progressivism is you got to know where
you're going it implies that you've got
a direction if you find that you're
going down the wrong road then the first
guy to turn around and walk in the other
direction is the true progressive
another important lesson here from all
of this mourning and weeping and
gnashing of teeth over Qasem Soleimani
may he rest in hell is don't be defined
simply by what you were against okay if
you are just fanatically against Trump
if that is the definition of your
political philosophy you're gonna wind
up defending terrorists because anybody
that Trump is against you're gonna be
for like the mainstream media and Ti and
IOC and Bernie and George Lopez and all
these people right I'm not saying
they're all terrible people I actually
don't think most of them are terrible
people I think they're extraordinarily
misguided and they've allowed this
fanatical anti Trump political ideology
to make them side with terrorists and
mullahs don't do that you've got to be
for something you can't look I'm against
Hillary Clinton I'm against Barack Obama
I'm against leftism but I'm also for
something else which is a conservative
worldview the American tradition the
American Founding I'm for a virtuous
politics I'm for the Christian
understanding of the world that has
formed the basis of our politics I'm for
all of those things you got to be for
something if you want to have a
political vision that doesn't lead you
to defend the indefensible a lot of
political division in this country I
think around the world even comes from
the fact that even when the left
pretends to be for something they're
actually just against something they're
using what they pretend to be for as a
mask to just hide that they're merely
opposed to something else I know that's
a little confusing so I'll give you an
example the me2 movement the me2
movement is the perfect example of this
the UK just yesterday just sentenced the
most
prolific rapists in British history - to
life in prison this rapist was convicted
of raping 48 victims but he actually
raped many more 195 victims were filmed
being raped in his apartment those are
just the ones who got filmed you
probably haven't heard about this story
the mainstream media is not really
reporting on it why because it doesn't
fit the me2 narrative of rich powerful
American white men raping women in this
case it was an Indonesian man who raped
men it was a gay guy so it's just not in
the news I doubt you've seen it anywhere
or heard it anywhere other than on this
show this is the me to story to end all
me two stories the most prolific rapist
in British history gone because so often
the political activists who are running
the me2 movement are not really for
defending victims of sexual assault
they're not really for changing a
culture of sexual violence or a rape
culture is the popular term that's being
used on the Left they're not really for
that they simply use it as a political
cudgel to take down people that they
don't like so some of them were complete
derelicts I mean these guys in Hollywood
are absolute criminals but they're awful
in some cases if they're not criminals
they're just really scummy skeezy people
but it's really about taking somebody
down rather than pushing forward a
positive message I'll give you give you
another example of this the same story
happened last month there was an
anti-semitic attack in New Jersey there
was that there were a number of
anti-semitic attacks actually all around
the tri-state area
what happened after that is Rashidah
Talib Rasheeda Talib the congresswoman
the the member of the squad comes out
and says that this is an example of how
white supremacy kills and then the news
came out that it wasn't a white
supremacist who committed the
actually it was black supremacist a
member of the Hebrew Israelites what had
received to Rasheeda Talib do did she
change her tweet did she post actually
black supremacy can kill two actually
racial hatred knows no color actually
everybody can be guilty of this because
man's heart is evil from the beginning
no she didn't do any of that she just
deleted the tweet because the minute
that this attack didn't correspond with
her leftist narrative she had to get rid
of it she had to bury it she had to
forget about it she had to pretend it
wasn't real whole spate of anti-semitic
attacks going on in New York currently
but because it doesn't fit the narrative
because in many cases the perpetrators
are black rather than white then we
forget about it it's gone it's out of
the mainstream media and then these
leftists have the audacity to malign all
of us as not taking racial attacks
seriously is not taking sexual attacks
seriously in reality we are taking these
sorts of things much more seriously than
the left much more seriously we take it
seriously regardless of the perpetrators
race or sex or the victims race or sex
the left only cynically uses these
incidents when it suits their narrative
they have no credibility whatsoever no
moral authority whatsoever on these
issues you know to the question of
authority to the question of
accountability T I brought up
accountability of all people a Hollywood
leftist Joaquin Phoenix actually raised
this point at the Golden Globes and in
an otherwise kind of meandering strange
left-wing message he actually had an
important thing to say to Hollywood and
to the left more broadly we'll get to
that in a second then we'll get to the
big little endorsements in 2020 we'll
get to who won the coveted Judge Judy
endorsement and then we will get to why
the Methodist Church is splitting up
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube head on over to
daily wire.com you get me you get the
end of life and show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
you get another Kingdom
you get the leftist ears tumblr make
sure you head over there right now daily
wire comm we'll be right back with a lot
more
Joaquin Phoenix had an important message
at the Golden Globes it kind of got
buried because Ricky Gervais stabbed
salutely killed it the other night and
Michelle Williams gave a very stupid
speech about abortion so so this moment
was not really promoted all over the
internet but it's an important one on
the question of accountability on the
question of how our political
philosophies relate to ourselves and
relate to politics
Joaquin Phoenix said that if you want to
make change in the world you want a
virtuous world you want a good politics
you've got to start with yourself it's
great to vote but sometimes we have to
take that responsibility on ourselves
and make changes and sacrifices in our
own lives and I hope that we can do that
we don't have to take private jets to
Palm Springs for the awards sometimes or
back please and I'll try to do better
and I hope you will too thank you so
much for putting up with me so on this
issue he's just talking about global
warming right he's saying we're having
this Golden Globes awards dinner you're
all eating vegan to make a big message
you're all gonna go vote for Liz Warren
or somebody but in your own personal
lives you don't really live up to what
you proclaim on television and when you
go to the voting booth because you all
take private jets which are horrible for
the environment so really what you've
got to do is just start looking at the
man in the mirror and shape up your own
life and then you'll have a virtuous
Society the minute he suggests this the
minute he says hey leftists who are all
prattling on about climate change maybe
don't fly as many private jets they
start playing them off you can hear the
music start to rise up in the clip it's
a it's an important note if you want a
virtuous society you have to practice
virtue all of these guys George Lopez
Bernie Sanders aoc Michael Moore all the
ones who are siding now with the
Ayatollah / president Trump because of
how awful and immoral the ia awful and
immoral Trump is take a look at yourself
take a look at who you're defending take
a look at who your friends are take a
look at who you're aligning with take a
look at how you're behaving I mean
George Lopez said will kill the
President of the United States for only
40 million we hate him so much
why why are you gonna kill the president
because he says mean things on the
Internet hey buddy take a look in the
mirror why are you gonna kill the
president because he's disrespectful of
his country and his countrymen you just
threatened to kill the president
take a look in the mirror okay if you
want a virtuous Society it is not enough
to vote a certain way or to have the
right bumper sticker on your car you
have to practice the virtue
I mean how absurd is it for you to
demand that other people practice virtue
including the President of the United
States when you're not even trying when
you're not even making an effort
you're not even trying and failing to
live up to virtue you're just taking the
vicious potshots from your own corner
and aligned with the worst people on
earth while you harangue people like
Donald Trump for not living up to this
Madisonian George Washington II an ideal
of the American leadership take a look
in the mirror now speaking of the
political scene and the Future Leaders
of America we've got some major little
endorsements in the 2020 Democratic
presidential primary before we get to
the coveted Judge Judy endorsement there
is the question of who Leon Castro my
favorite Democratic candidate the bold
leader who endorsed abortion rights for
men in a democratic debate he dropped
out obviously because nobody supported
him in the whole country he is now
choosing to endorse drum roll please
Elizabeth Warren he says that Elizabeth
Warren is the most qualified
best-equipped candidate to win the
nomination that is not true but he is
endorsing her anyway this is maybe a
smart move for Castro it's one of the
only two moves he could have made he
can't endorse Biden because he
humiliated Biden on stage and said that
he was an old man who was had dementia
and was forgetting things that he said
two minutes before I was really really
ugly attack he's not going to go for
Buddha
because Budaj edge is now playing the
moderate role in the race and castro
decided to play the far left to stroll
in the race endorsing abortion for men
so that leaves Warren and Sanders now
Sanders is the the real deal radical
right Sanders honeymooned in the Soviet
Union
Sanders was friends with Karl Marx I
think I'm pretty sure I think was Marx
angles and Sanders who were drafting the
Communist Manifesto
or Bernie was left out so he could go
for Sanders the real deal radical or he
could go for Warren who is the more
cynical radical Ward has positioned
herself as an establishment figure at
various times in her life and she's
positioned herself as a radical now she
doesn't have much regard for the truth
the same thing could be said of who Leon
Castro who Leon Castro was a Clinton
democrat until the day before yesterday
when he thought it would behoove him to
move for it further to the left he's a
real calculating politician so he sees a
similar figure in the Elizabeth Warren
now I think if he were really making a
play for 2020 he probably would have
gone for Sanders I think right now
Sanders has a better chance of getting
this nomination Sanders is vastly out
raising Elizabeth Warren he's vastly out
raising everybody in the field and he's
actually standing for something he is
sort of outside the mainstream which at
this moment in politics is pretty
helpful and Elizabeth Warren is tanking
right her momentum is totally dropped it
doesn't exist anymore and Sanders is
gaining momentum so if he were really
concerned about 2020 probably Castro
would have endorsed Sanders but I think
Castro is looking down the road I think
the whole Democratic Party is not
terribly hopeful that they're gonna win
in 2020 they don't really have a
top-tier candidate so I think he's
looking at 2024 2028 he's saying you
know Bernie Sanders is pretty up there
at age and Elizabeth Warren has a long
career ahead of her this might be a good
partnership to begin and especially
right now that Liz Warren's stock is
dropping that it's he could he could buy
pretty cheap that she needs these sort
of endorsements I think he thinks that
his endorsement is going to go
significantly further with Elizabeth
Warren this is a signal of the weakness
of the Warren campaign
the fact that she's got to pick up these
cheap little endorsements right now the
fact that they would be so helpful to
the people who are endorsing another
candidate to trot out an endorsement
this week was Michael Bloomberg you
might have forgotten that former New
York City half Republican half Democrat
billionaire extraordinaire Mike
Bloomberg was running Bloomberg trotted
out the coveted Judge Judy endorsement
here she is
I'm Judge Judy Scheindlin I like to say
you can judge someone's character by
what they've done Mike Bloomberg has
done amazing things and will be a truly
great president no one comes close to
Mike Bloomberg the executive achievement
government experience and impactful
philanthropy his steady leadership will
unite our country and bring us through
these very challenging times I'm Mike
Bloomberg and I approve this message all
right you got it Mike congratulations
this highlights the central problem with
the Bloomberg campaign which is that
there's nobody to vote for him nobody
likes his point of view which is as a
sort of fiscal conservative you might
say or low taxes pro-free trade pro
freedom generally Pro free market
economics guy and a big social liberal
who wants to take away all of our guns
and promote a radical social agenda
abortion the whole nine yards every
elite person on the coasts who went to
very fancy schools who has a very fancy
job everybody in that social strata
believes what Mike Bloomberg believes
but they account for like 4% of the
country I didn't think the actual number
according to polling is four to four and
a half percent who would call themselves
fiscal conservative social liberals like
Mike Bloomberg and so if there's just no
audience for this I mean Judge Judy
she's a celebrity New Yorker who's a
kind of political moderate so she is a
natural fit for Mike Bloomberg but very
few people fit that bill it's a evidence
even further of an astroturf campaign
another good evidence of this yesterday
team Bloomberg Bloomberg campaign
Twitter account posted a photo a
Bloomberg somewhere on the campaign
trail at a barbecue joint and it says
find someone who looks at you the way
Mike looks at ribs with the big googly
eyes emoji and the trouble with the
photo is that nobody is eating ribs
they're actually eating brisket
the only ribs in the photo are human
ribs and if that's what the team was
implying there with the tweet that's
pretty creepy really what you need to do
is find someone who knows what ribs are
unlike the Mike Bloomberg staffer who
posted that tweet it's all just
astroturf I don't think Mike Bloomberg
eats ribs I don't think Mike Bloomberg
rolls his shirt sleeves up I think Mike
Bloomberg is a very fancy billionaire
who has lived in New York for his entire
life who drinks very good wines and who
talks to very elite people about very
elite things and which is perfectly fine
I think he should be him I think he's
gonna have a much better job convincing
people that that's who he is rather than
that he's some working-class guy who
doesn't even know what ribs are but it
shows you a key aspect of Trump's appeal
which is that he is a billionaire who
doesn't act like a billionaire he is a
billionaire who doesn't talk fancy he
talks like a construction worker
it always has it's not like he's putting
on a show to run for president he has
always talked that way he's a
billionaire who wants to eat KFC rather
than all the fancy food that Mike
Bloomberg eats right he's a billionaire
who actually probably knows what ribs
are he's a billionaire who famously when
the orders steak he orders it burnt with
ketchup
he doesn't order steak tartare with a
very nice chef Lior at albariño wine and
thus awright he doesn't do that he
drinks Diet Coke he actually doesn't
drink alcohol at all that is a real
political advantage for Trump these guys
are just Jokers in the Democratic field
and if the recent endorsements are any
indication it's not getting better for
them before we go I've got to talk about
the Methodist Church splitting up the
United Methodist Church leaders are now
proposing a split in their church to
resolve a debate over
LGBTQ clergy and same-sex weddings so
they're active and that's pretty radical
they're talking about the church
actually officiating same-sex wedding
ceremonies this is a proposal from the
16 member group of bishops and church
leaders and they say the separation may
be quote the best means to resolve our
differences allowing each part of the
church to remain true to its theological
understanding while recognizing the
dignity equality integrity and respect
of every person so they can't figure out
this question of radical social
progressivism I guess you would call her
leftism
and so now they're going to split up I
mentioned the story for a couple of
reasons one it's to show you that it's a
fool's errand for the church to try to
become more like the world every
Christian denomination has done this at
various points including maybe
especially the Catholic Church they've
tried to become more like the world they
say if only we more closely resemble the
world then we'll be able to attract
people to our pews and what happened the
exact opposite proved true when the
mainstream Protestant churches in
America tried to become more modern more
hip more cool more like the world the
pews emptied out when the Catholic
Church tried to become more modern more
hip more cool more like the world after
vatican ii guess what happened the pews
emptied at the only people who go to
church anymore the only people who were
increasing their church attendance are
the traditionalists who are going to
latin masses ever since pope benedict
permitted the latin mass again the same
thing is true in evangelical churches
the ones that try to become more hip and
more cool and more like the world with a
few exceptions are the ones that empty
out and the ones that try to preach a
more orthodox message those are the ones
that fill up that's one aspect of this
story the other one is to just show one
of the arguments for the catholic church
because i get these questions all the
time in the mailbag this why are you
Catholic and I usually give theological
answers to that or answers from
symbolism or from literature from the
nature of language or philosophical I
write this is just a very practical
reason for the Catholic Church which is
after you had the paratus
revolution you got tens of thousands of
different Protestants nominations each
claiming to be the truth each claiming
to represent the truth of the Bible you
know to be a Bible Church or the truth
of the apostolic tradition or the truth
of Christian history or whatever they
can't all be right there has to be some
Authority and this argument that that
actually does sort of come from the
authority of the apostolic tradition
refers to a passage in scripture where
Christ looks at his apostles and they
had the ones who haven't left him after
he makes the hard saying about the
Eucharist after he says you've got to
eat my flesh and drink my blood or you
have no life in you a lot of people go
away and then as a possible stay and he
says you haven't left me and Peter says
where shall we go where else could we go
and that is the argument for
Christianity from Authority and
specifically for the Catholic Church I
mean that that is one that refers
directly to that authority because if
you crack that authority then you get
thirty thousand different denominations
that split up you know every few weeks
it would seem and that authority is
important in politics too it's not
sufficient it can't be the only argument
but when you look at your political
point of view and you see that it's
leading you to oppose the very bonds of
loyalty to your country themselves that
they lead you to oppose your tradition
they lead you to oppose your own
countrymen and decide with vicious
terrorists and the worst people on earth
maybe you've got to rethink your point
of view that's true politically
culturally it's true all the way up the
line all the way up to religious
questions there are practical effects of
ideas in in the real world they will
lead you to real human interaction they
will lead you to real political
institutions to put it simply ideas
matter and if all of the matter around
you of all of the relationships around
you seem to be a little off kilter if if
all
the actions that you're being impelled
to do is seem a little off-kilter than
maybe you've got to change the ideas
that's our show I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nell show us a tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling our technical producer is
Austin Stephens assistant director havel
we Dowe ski editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and make-up Jeshua alvera
production assistant McKenna
waters the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20:19 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there